we are walking in culated town and all
these people are
actors I don't needs I'm on tevion I
think
all right 5 minute warning start getting
fitted for your guys out TVs thank you
wow links huh excuse
me what the fuck was that
get oh got it oh my god did anyone here
work on the set of
Rush you're going to come up me you yep
but I'm not going to pull an out all one
I'm going to put the gun down when I R
should I do it this
way so now you're going to make sure
that weapon's down and safe kick
it got C boom you're it oh we got them
they didn't even want to us yeah we all
right watch it
oh my God here you go select down
fire Panda did you just have a panic
attack or what just happened no um as
you can see I'm totally fine we don't
have time for your your trial traa right
now Hannah come on we got to prove that
them women are equal let's go my tanic
membrane is rubbed to
go
got you here oh you got to the door go
go go
go good good should we share who we were
imagining I just want be clear I would
be in a foxhole with Whitney and dude in
a comedy club if you don't think I've
been wanting to open a strip club called
Foxhole for a while now out of your mind
boom boom boom I get why guys love guns
it's like coming it is just like G yeah
makes me feel like I just got someone
pregnant did anyone notice Hannah
literally came up and she was
like why was I running like
that oh target
practice my god I've never been punched
by air before where in Texas okay should
I do it like this you can do yeah so
usually the way Shooters hold it they
come in here put in their shoulder you
good I'm good I'm good I got they'll put
it in their shoulder like this and then
they'll hold right here on the butt and
they'll pull
the you got down on one knee and I got
fral I love this not what R
it oh a here it is here it is oh my God
about to get
CTE I think that's what I sound like to
men when I talk can only dat people in
the military CU they're death exactly
now you
know that's why people in the military
love me I think I just figured it
out they can't hear
me I hope they shooting blanks I took my
IUD
out I love that
feeling yes can you help us perur spouse
today I'm Wendy Cummings and I'm a black
horse
Trooper thank you thanks for having us
why have I decided I'm the 2023 Marilyn
Monroe of the military I'm just
like